j'accuse adresse je suis ravi qu'on
lance kit été élu meilleur réalisateur
mais non attends j'ai été violé ma foi
donc j'ai pas mal mais j'avais envie de
dieu qu'elle reste film alors isabelle
il ya eu plein de réactions sur twitter
hier et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens voilà qui devrait premier tweet
d'anaïs elle n'a pas compris vos propos
isabelle morini bosc a perdu l'occasion
de se taire je laime beaucoup comme
chroniqueuse mais là je ne comprend pas
la prise de position le second truc
isabelle morini-bosc représente les
femmes violi de l'ancienne époque des
femmes qui normalise le viol qui
soutiennent les violeurs et les
agresseurs elle est là pour elle c'était
simplement une épreuve de la vie elles
sont déconnectés de cette nouvelle
génération suède avait arrêté j'ai
entendu des idioties un dans ma vie mais
alors une comme c'est le 6 mai mais
rarement de voir de quel droit qu'est ce
qu'elle juge exactement une épreuve de
la vie qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
est lancé
c'est pas du tout c'est simplement que
c'est ma nature profonde quand j'ai un
problème bram de le garder pour moi
mais quand j'entends une jeune femme
dire tu méritera dans le fond des
manifestants
tu mériterais de viol et à ton tour un
jour c'est pour ça que je me suis
retournée moi qui n'en parle jamais je
lui dis je l'étais j'en fais ni une
affaire d'état ni un titre de gloire
parce que même parer tout le monde sort
du bois en disant j'ai été violée
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est c'est
un non sens absolu
elles ont faim de gloire ses courses et
la parole s'est libérée on a vu un
hashtag hier qui a sorti et qui fait du
bien cela que j'ai donné couzier
découvert histoire de nadège
beausson-diagne que j'adore nadège qui
ont redit que ce qu'on voit là qui
étaient avec nous et qu'on aime est
vraiment chez ces voix là je viens
aujourd'hui même pour qu'ils viennent
nous voir et c'est vrai qu'on a déjà les
sorties voilà de son silence et à l'ami
de tweet a été violée par deux fois par
une femme et par un homme
et c'est vrai que voilà c'est moi je
veux dire des témoignages comme ça ça
fait du bien aussi de les voir sur les
réseaux sociaux et nadège en tout cas on
te soutient très fort ma chérie on
t'aime fort et
voilà on sera toujours là pour toi et
tes mais garde son sourire qui est
vraiment à un soleil oui mais fardani
moigne normalise le viol soutiennent des
violeurs en quoi ce que j'ai dit permet
de dire que je normalise le biais je
vous dis soutien à quelqu'un qui est
d'isabelle morini-bosc porte-parole des
violeurs en france je sais c'est par
rapport à votre soutien à roman polanski
qu'est ce que vous aimez alors on met
vraiment on est dans une société
pardonnez-moi 2.0 qui mélange absolument
tout effectivement si on voulait pas
qu'il fasse des films fallait
l'interdire c'est un film important sur
lentilly dix jeunes est jugé que ça pour
lens qui je connais certainement mieux
polanski qu'elle ne connaisse elle même
parce que depuis le début je suis son
histoire il a perdu la moitié de sa
famille dans l'est dans les camps il a
ému une femme assassinée avec son bébé
donc j'ai entendu quelqu'un dire le même
soir il mériterait de souffrir un jour
maintenant faisons lui le crédit d'avoir
quand même déjà souffert il a fait ça en
quoi j'ai normalement doit percevoir
qu'edward assez il doit être jugé par
ailleurs s'enferme et bien sûr que non
mais ne mélangeons je vous en supplie ne
mélangeons pas tout ce soir là on juge
un film après il ya le temps de la
justice et balcons kid qu'on le fasse
repasser au tribunal qu'on extra nicon
l'extra d'ipa mais c'est un autre c'est
un autre débat c'est un autre problème
là on juger un film et leur dire que je
normalise le viol de jeu soutien des
mollahs
qu'est ce qu'ils savent de ce que j'ai
souffert vous avez souffert vous dis
bien évidemment ma dernière tentative de
viol cia quatre ans par st james à 8
heures du matin de près du centre
équestre où le mec est arrivée ma
ceinture et par derrière ce qu'on s'en
fout des crâneuse mais je vous garantis
quand le mec arrive vous soutient le
bras les mains vous ne pouvait
strictement plus rien faire il m'a
couché dans l'air je voyais passer les
camions les airs météo personne ne me
voyait j'ai une cicatrice dans le dos
parce que mon dos ou à appuyer sur la
cicatrice pendant pendant deux heures le
monsieur n'a pas réussi à mettre de
braguette et une amie ce partout
ailleurs dans les yeux dans les oreilles
dans la bouche et où j'étais glacé
sauf que j'ai un truc qui me sauve c'est
que j'ai quelque chose qui fait
exactement comme dans un hôpital vous
avez le tout le secteur qui sont
l'électricité qui semblait vous avez un
blog secours qui se met en place
et ben moi quand je suis tétanisé j'ai
un respect ça m'est arrivé plusieurs
fois j'ai y compris quand j'étais petit
j'ai un espèce de truc qui se met en
place et qui agit littéralement à ma
place qui fait que je garde un sang
froid du début à la fin ça quand même
duré deux heures et demie j'ai des cons
c'est vraiment de tétaniser oui j'étais
complètement tétanisés
sur le sol et après j'ai eu qu'une envie
c'est de rentrer chez moi me doucher et
aller retrouver mon mari qui rentrait de
haute savoie et j'ai importé plan qu'ils
veulent c'est ça non je suis pas les
porter plainte ce que je me sentais
vraiment salies je vais surtout envie de
me doucher après après que régime
j'aime honnêtement j ai même pas pensé
j'avais ça ne me servait des gens
allaient aller dès l'après midi parce
qu'une sorte de soutien de famille et
j'avais je voulais pas faire faux bond à
la personne alors il s'agit même pas
pensé mais bon il n'y ai même pas pensé
c'est pour ça que quand on a les reins
les réseaux sociaux si ça sert à ça
aussi peut-être aussi à développer aussi
une parole et peut-être à libérer la
parole c'est pas la première fois en
plus les autres fois isabelle ou où vous
avez été agressée est-ce que vous avez
porté plainte alors je vais j'ai des
amis flic donc sans le sang année porté
plainte je leur ai raconté ils ont
enregistré mes propos oui mais mettons
et alors si je comprends bien c'est la
triple peine quoi on souffre on on se
redresse
on continue à aller de l'avant à ce
qu'il faut c'est important mais dix
minutes et pense aux autres alors non
mais dans 5 minutes en soi même on va me
cloue au pilori 10 ans croquait la main
aux autres l'arrêt du tournage et on
dirait vous avez pour mettre hors d'état
de nuire les ont des agresseurs ont dit
qu'en 2020 maintenant on dit qu'en 2020
maintenant il faut pas laisser passer ça
faut avoir la force il faut rentrer chez
soit remis en 2024
c'est moi je parle je connais rien à ce
sujet là et je pars je dis juste
maintenant il ya le hashtag je suis une
victime il ya des trucs comme il a dit
sir il ya internet on peut plus laisser
passer ça en envoie entre on prend une
douche et je demande la famille cela
peut avoir la force d'aller déposer des
plaintes faut que les femmes elles elles
informeront saison jusqu'à maintenant
c'est pas culpabiliser
le tout que vous avez montré le même
mine de vous nommer ses sources par les
violeurs et le viol mais c'est indigne
de dire ça on sait très bien que ce
n'est pas le cas ils ne savaient pour
montrer à quel point les gens disaient
que j'avais encore dans l'idée qu'il
faut surtout pas lire ces trucs là il y
avait ma chérie vraiment moi je vous dis
on vous aime
on sait ce que vous valez ça mais je la
regarde
un vrai profil avec toi ça genre sont
fiers de dire des trucs comme ça quoi
je soutiens fine que j'étais important
elle est où la liberté de penser aller
où la démocratie là dedans c'est
vraiment une c'est la nouvelle dictature
est l'ennemi de dieu
ouais c'est vrai voilà c'est vrai je
vous fais un coup alors là alors là
vraiment ça me troue le cul pour parler
vulgairement vous mais si ça me
permettre isabelle je pense que les gens
savent que vous valez après on dira
toujours des bêtises jamais rien et des
gens qui ne connaissent pas votre
histoire
à
et c'est isabelle qui sont brandis de la
fréquence à temps
c'est vous qui sortis grandis la
séquence des gènes et on attend les
violeurs